Film Courage: What are your five tips for getting a
movie made? Dale Stelly, Writer/Director/Producer: Five tips for getting a movie
made? First of all have a good genre.
You know do your homework on a genre. Be
persistent with your movie package. You
know you got a probably send the movie
package you know have a good
presentation which is your
movie package. A positive attitude which
is energy,
positive attitude, always got to stay
positive nice...package you say five tips?
For me five tips of getting a film made
is always staying positive,
knowing who to approach you know
executive producers you know I mean you
got that like do your due diligence as
far as like when you're trying to seek
you know funding you know what I mean so
you know having the right script
obviously a marketable script doing your
due diligence on on pitching your
package then you do diligence on the
people that you're inquiring you know
funding about you know I mean so that is 3.
Movie package, your investors, the script
and then the crew you know surrounding
yourself with a good crew. That's that
pulls for you that that is basically you
know on a same wavelength as you like
understand your vision that's not gonna
walk away offset you know because you
know they didn't bring a vegetarian food
or something like that you know I mean
like you know having a solid crew and
basically, let me see what was number five? I say
crew to package to script target you're
right investors and five faith in
yourself
yeah I think most important is having
faith in yourself and in others and
and things were you know come to life
have you always had faith in yourself
yeah I have sometimes I think I have too
much faith myself but I'm not I
definitely believe in my my powers of
creating and bringing people together
bringing people together to reach a
common goal you know that's in life or
in film you know like definitely Dean
you know being confident in what I want
and what I want to happen or where I
want to manifest the confidence and
faith is definitely you know you got to
have that in you because if you don't
have that in you then people won't
gravitate to you you know what I mean
people gravitate to energy and you walk
around with positive energy believing in
yourself and people are seeing the
results of you believe in yourself and
creating stuff that's the whole thing
people need to see you on your journey
you know what I mean you need to see you
create on your journey if people not
seeing what you're doing they're just
hearing about it if they need to hear
and see and that's how people actually
become you know I mean successful or
become like confident because people
seeing results and they're not only
hearing about it seeing it so that's why
it's so good the time that we live in
now with social media because now people
can actually see you live in your dreams
you're not just talking about you can
see like oh what's it oh I'm writing on
this script
or I'm working with this actor today
like people start gravitating to your to
your progress you know what I mean but
people don't see any progress or they
don't know what to believe you know what
I mean for me I've been doing the same
thing for the last you know 20 going on
24 years since 1995 I mean doing
production everyone knows we have not
straight away to try anything else I
mean strictly entertainment business
since people have known me
and to me that's is a good trait to have
because a lot of people in this business
you know if they don't get what they
want right away they go and try
something else or they don't get results
right away you know like ah that's not
for me but me I know creating in in and
doing and producing directing movies is
my it's my calling like creating is my
calling so you know gotta stick to it
and through thick and thin and I've been
able to you know keep a roof over my
head that way so confidence sounds like
it's sort of unshakable but faith is
really knowing like it's gonna work out
if you do the right you know things
which is your homework and putting
effort into your goals and in having
faith in yourself it's going to work out
eventually it's gonna work out when I
work out overnight but I'm here to tell
everyone out there that hard work pays
off in this town just a lot of people
not willing to put in it because
everybody wants everything right now
right now everything is quick quick
everything you know you have to go
shopping no more just order online every
day I do you want everything now and but
the people that you know that realize
how the universe works and realize that
when you putting that effort in the
University in those goals that you're
trying to get and you're working towards
it you will eventually achieve them but
they're not gonna happen you know like
that without putting any thought into it
or any effort into it you know what I
mean have you seen people with faith in
themselves but no confidence so no one
believes in them yeah yeah there's a
couple people that you know I like to
try to enlighten people and try to
motivate people and try and inspire
people and you know in this business you
come across people that are here one day
and then they're there the next day or
you know how to be vice versa and yeah
when I see what I see talent in people
sometimes they just need to hear a voice
to push them right hey you on the right
track I like what you're doing and don't
stop you know like when you give up is
usually when you about to get
I'm saying you're bright you know what I
mean so there's there's been there's
been times where you know I felt like I
didn't get you know my due diligence
from a project or I didn't get the
reward or the compensation that I
thought but you know I just dust it off
and I'm like I'm gonna get it from
another project just you can always get
a reward or big accolades or something
from the next project that you didn't
get from previously you know what I mean
like I always know like dividing you pay
down on this project or I didn't make a
lot of money or make them laugh supposed
to I know God is gonna bless me and give
it to me in a different way on another
project like I feel like all the energy
in a you know money and a compensation
that you lost or earned or whatever is
always gonna be there is just a way of
you keep on creating and manifesting so
if you did lose something here you'll be
able to get it on something else like I
know what my movie Compton's Finest
like there are some movies where I
didn't make the profit that I thought I
was going to make on it but I know with
the profit that I'm gonna make on
Compton's - it's gonna make up for all
the properties that I lost in the past
so when you stay positive and just know
like y'all to stay positive just keep
putting that that good energy out there
and in hard work will eventually pay off
like you know you just take the good
with the bad but just know that it's
always gonna be all good in the end
you said something earlier about how
this is your calling but how do you know
this is your calling I notice is my
column because I have produced miracles
when it comes to getting somebody's
films produced especially with the
budgets and with the parameters and with
you know certain situations that have
come to light in my favor and to be you
know I'm 44 just had a birthday December
1st and to produce 30 feature films with
distribution in place since I was with
my first movie out in 2002 so to do 30
movies in 17 some odd years
it's definitely telling me that this is
my calling because a lot of people do
one two films and you know they hang it
up because it takes a lot of dedication
and hard work to just stick to this
movie business because you know not
everything is glamorous people think
everything is good sing glamour and you
know money and have you but there's only
so many really actors and filmmakers are
really you know making a lot of you know
being compensated you know in you know
immensely in there's some of us that
that's doing important love and know
that eventually you know the money will
follow you know the passion but you know
I'm doing this because I'm I'm very you
know very creative and and I like
working with people and I know that my
creativity kid eventually you know lead
to a lot of money for myself and for
people that's involved in the business
so you know people want to work with
people that's gonna make you know money
so there's a passion about me but at the
same time as a business about me that I
have to get paid off my passion you know
what I mean so you know ya want to work
with people that want to make creative
product that produces profits and at the
same time do you feel like there's
probably nothing else you could do that
this is it this is what you want to do I
mean I don't want to entertain anything
else but I mean me I'm smart I can learn
things quicken in a way with technology
and everything is now I know that if
Hollywood went away and there was no more
cameras or no you know I mean no more
Hollywood system people weren't
entertained by films or videos anymore
like now I know I could figure out
another way to make you know income you
know what I mean but my passion and just
knowing you know friends and people that
make an enormous living you know in this
business I just feel like I'm in lying
I'm next and I've been in line you know
for a while and I can actually see like
at the end of the tunnel where you know
I'm going to give my due diligence
everyone that you know supported me I
was down with me from day one you know
we're all going to come back together
again and celebrate and I want to take
care of everybody that you know that
supported me and invested in me and got
behind me because this thing is is was
like a dream you know morning like
20-something years ago and now is a
living dream and now my company's been
around 20 years and you know there's ups
and downs with any would any business
and I don't think nobody's business is
all unless you're Apple or something
like that but even Apple take something
it you know hit some criticism sometimes
but yeah you know you live and learn and
you stay you know you stay positive and
stay focused and I've been able to you
know stay in in the you know stay not in
the limelight would stay afloat and keep
having opportunities you know coming
away
you